all right joining us now with reaction
Fox Business host Charles Payne
there's there actually was three Maureen
Dowd writing the story about the
granddaughter that they wouldn't
recognize the second is the media mop
CNN's poll put CNN's on-air comments
about Joe
um you know van Jones is like a little
grandpa that you really want to save
from himself and not let run pretty
profound yeah I'm waiting for the big
the first big name Democrat to follow
suit it's going to happen soon because
this is a very slippery slope at this
point and the numbers are the numbers
Sean and Dan Jones asked a question that
every American voter should be asking do
you think this President will get better
with age or worse with age it's a
rhetorical question right do you want
the 86 year old version of Joe Biden in
the Oval Office which he will be if he
wins a second term but forget about age
for a second because I think that's an
excuse do you like the way the economy
and bidenomics is going for you right
now do you like are you better off than
you are four years ago exactly that
worked didn't it are you happy do you
feel safely in your own communities
given what's happening with crime are
you happy with the fact that seven
million people have entered this country
illegally what's 7 million 38 individual
U.S states don't have a population of 7
million yet that's what's been happening
including hundreds on the terror watch
list are you happy with the fact we just
sent 520 million dollars to Ukraine to
make their energy cleaner I could go on
Sean do you like the fact that would you
agree with this that's more money going
to the people of Ukraine than Maui in
Hawaii or the people of Florida hundreds
still missing maybe a thousand dead and
we're we're treating Ukraine better than
Maui but most importantly do you think
that abortion shouldn't be should be
carried out in the second or third turn
turn that argument on its head because
most Americans don't agree with that
either way if you ask those questions
and it becomes an issues-based election
Democrats are in big trouble regardless
of who the nominee is Sean Charles Payne
I just read all the statistics you just
heard from Joe uh how much trouble is he
now in he's in he's out of trouble but
it's going to get a lot worse the Trends
on the economic data are frightening
frightening we see the the smallest
Banks right now they're delinquency
rates are seven and a half percent is
off the rails but the large banks are
turning up uh credit card interest rates
just crack 22 percent uh as defaults are
going through the roof uh it's all the
in the economic indicators point to
extreme pain and it's going to be
exponential like you know on my show
today I talked about the Ernest
Hemingway you know how did you go
bankrupt versus gradual then Sutton this
is what we're going it's gradual and
then it's going to feel like a rocket
ship it's going to feel like a rocket
ship and and Americans just aren't
prepared for it uh you know all the free
stemi money is gone uh we're still
dealing with inflation people are trying
to batten down the houses we're about to
go to 100 a barrel for oil our gasoline
inventory is at a five-year low uh
obviously the Strategic petroleum
reserves the 1983. four dollars may look
like may look cheap three months from
now four dollars may look cheap but it
looked like the good old days three four
months from now the trajection right now
that that we're on all the indicators
point to what we're feeling right now is
just the very tip of the iceberg it's
going to get a whole lot worse and the
Saudis also said they're going to
continue their lower production levels
Saudi Arabia and Russia announced it uh
20 minutes within each other yeah we're
going to keep coincidentally so are we
YouTube yeah we're going to keep these
production Cuts up for through the end
of the year but you know why decide why
wouldn't they and by the way they got a
friend in the White House President
Biden he's all of a sudden he just
snatches these leases that were signed
uh 430 000 acres in any Arctic all of a
sudden he says well we don't want to put
natural gas on on trains all right but
you're against pipelines also the war of
fossil fuels is going to have a
deleterra it's already crushing people
but to your point all of this stuff is
is going to get a whole lot worse so
these numbers that you're talking about
right now it's as tough as as hard as it
is to believe all right they could get
worse so Joe they're going to need a
replacement
I don't think common law is that person
now it was interesting this week to
watch Kamala Harris at least people
around her I'm convinced leaked the
story well if Gavin Newsom jumps in uh
that would not go over well with the
minority uh communities and and people
of color et cetera Etc uh shot across
his bow to tell him you better stay out
of this Sean you look at polling and you
talked about Joe Biden being as low as
Jimmy Carter 39 it's not a place you
want to be if you're running for
election you know where Kamala Harris is
she's a 32 percent that is the lowest of
any vice president in history she was
supposed to be Plan B I'm not sure she's
even playing Z at this point because she
has an articulation problem she has an
authenticity problem she failed at the
U.S Southern border and we talked about
Joe Biden not being likable Kamala
Harris is profoundly not likable so
they're skipping right over her and to
your point Gavin Newsom probably is the
plan B so so are you convinced this is
going to happen
it's trending in that direction but
Democrats tend to be very loyal right
they stick together until Gavin Newsom
is given the go-ahead I'm not sure that
will but again what does the bumper
sticker look like make America
California because I'm pretty sure we
don't want that either high taxes High
homelessness and obviously a state how
about my hair doesn't blow in the wind
no okay I mean your hair doesn't blow me
and Gavin Newsom right I mean it's just
like all I've been doing is why would
they go to who would be you know what
they're in a real dicey predicament what
they do have working for them is that
what they proved the last election is
that it's no longer about passion it's
about an organization getting out the
vote you don't really have to have a you
know you know there was something about
going into a voting booth on Election
Day and pulling that lever something
that energized you now when you can
Harvest votes it almost doesn't matter
if we could just send someone to all the
houses on this map right the legal right
because if we can send everything to
someone to every house on this map and
pick up the ballot we'll feel it out for
you just initial it we'll fill it out
for you knock on your door so you don't
need to be passionately behind someone
Charles Payne Joe Contra great to see
you both hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else